malena's town is built on a grid similar
to the coordinate plane she is riding
her bicycle from her home at point
negative three comma four to the mall at
point negative three comma negative
seven
each unit on the graph denotes one city
block
plot the two points and find the
distance between melania's home and the
mall
so let's see they tell her she's riding
her bicycle from her home at the point
negative three comma four so let's plot
negative three comma four so i'll use
this point right over here so negative
three is our x coordinate so we're gonna
go three to the left of the origin one
two three that gets us to negative three
and positive 4 is our y coordinate so
we're going to go 4 above the origin or
i see we're going to go 4 up so we're
going to go 4 up so we went negative 3
or we went 3 to the left that's negative
positive 4. or you could say we went
positive 4
negative 3. this tells us what we do in
the horizontal direction this tells us
what we do in the vertical direction now
let's figure out that's where her home
is now let's figure out where the mall
is it's at the point negative 3 comma
negative 7.
so negative 3 we went 3
negative 3 along the horizontal
direction and then negative 7 along the
vertical direction
so we get to negative 3 negative 7 right
over there
now we need to figure out the distance
between her home and the mall and we
could actually count it out or we could
just compute if we wanted to count it
out it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 blocks
so we could type that in
and another way to think about it is
they have the exact same x axis
the exact same x coordinate they're both
at the x coordinate negative three the
only difference between these two is
what is happening in the y coordinate
this is at a positive four this is at a
negative seven positive four negative 7.
so we're really trying to find the
distance between 4 and negative 7. so if
i were to say 4 minus negative 7 we
would get this distance right over here
so we have 4 minus negative 7 which is
the same thing as 4 plus
7 which is 11.
let's do a couple more
carlos is hanging a poster in the area
shown by the red rectangle
he is placing a nail in the center of
the blue line
in the second graph in the second graph
plot the point where he places the nail
so he wants to place a nail in the
center of the blue line so the center of
the blue line the blue line is six units
long the center is right over here
that's three to the right it's three to
the left so he wants to plot he wants to
put the nail at the point x equals zero
y is equal to four
so he wants to put it at x is equal to
zero y is equal to four
that's this point right over here so
let's check our answer
let's do one more
a town town a and town b are connected
by a train that has a station at the
point negative one comma three i see
that the train tracks are in blue fair
enough which town is closer to the
station along the train route town a or
town b
so they're not just asking us what's the
kind of crows flight the distance the
distance that if you were to fly they're
saying the distance which town is closer
to the station along the train route so
if you were to follow the train route
just like that
so the a right over here a has you have
to go if you were going along the train
route you would have to go one two three
four five 6 in the x direction and then
1 2 3 4 5 along the y direction so you'd
have to go a total of 11.
if you're going from b you're going 1 2
3 4 5 six seven eight nine ten eleven
along the x direction and then
one two three four five six so six along
the vertical directions you're gonna go
total seventeen so it's pretty close
it's pretty obvious that a is closer
along the tracks now you could also
think about it in terms of coordinates
because the a is at the coordinate
negative seven comma eight
and if you were to think about negative
seven comma eight to get from negative
seven to negative one along the x
coordinates you're going to go six
and then to go from eight to three
you're gonna go five more so you could
also not necessarily count it out you
can actually just think about the
coordinates but either way you see that
town a is closer